[Music]
foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see uh what's making the headlines with
Camilla Turner Chief political
correspondent the Telegraph and Liam
Thorpe political editor at uh the
Liverpool Echo they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight welcome
to you both so let's see what's on some
of these front pages and the guardian
leads on this upcoming meeting between
prime minister truss and Richard Hughes
of the uh obr the headline PM holds
crunch talks with Watchdog over fiscal
chaos the eye has more on the market
crisis warning the Tory Wipeout after a
new poll suggests more than half of
Voters would back the labor party in a
general election and this record poll is
also featured on the front of the Metro
pretty starkly the headline labor lead
Tories by 33 points the party's largest
lead
in almost three decades economic turmoil
also covered by the telegraph or the
focus on benefit payments which are set
to fall despite Liz truss's attempts to
stem the bleeding
here's the times with a similar lead
their headline defiant PM set to curb
benefits to fund budget
the mail also has the story and the
government's plan to push forward with
the budget despite significant backlash
and the express goes with the peaceful
death of the queen it's on the front of
their paper as new details emerge after
the release of Her Majesty's death
certificate
and the sun features a story about the
ex-partner of TV presenter Fern Britain
and the Daily Star warns of robot
Armageddon just what we need they're
headline science friction uh warning of
unknown dangers of AI robots
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us and so we're joined tonight by
Camilla Turner and Liam Thorpe as I say
welcome
to you both let's start then uh Camilla
the guardian front page PM holds crunch
talks with Watchdog over fiscal chaos
and this is
highly unusual
yes that's right um the office for
Budget responsibility they're the fiscal
Watchdog of the UK
um have been due to publish their
forecast but not until November 23rd and
we learned today
um that they announced that the
chancellor has actually asked them to
bring us forward and published a draft
um in early October so this is a move
that I think is quite clearly aimed at
trying to reassure the conservative
party's own MPS about the economic
forecast
um as a result of the mini budget that
of course has caused turmoil in the
markets
um and and a wave of um sort of lack of
confidence through the British economy
and this Guardian story concentrates on
a meeting that Liz truss is going to
have with the head of the obr to discuss
this draft quite an unusual move but
clearly just showing that we're in this
really unprecedented period of economic
turmoil and the government not only want
to reassure them markets and get things
to calm down but also want to try and
reassure their own back Ventures and
bring them on side and convince them not
to rebel against some of these measures
they've got yeah and Liam I guess the
question is whether the meeting leads to
anything
yeah and also whether it's too late um I
think there's one one government Insider
told the guardian it's a bit like trying
to read the manual after you've broken
the the item already you know that this
is the obr that was essentially
sidelined by Liz Johnson and
quasi-quarters
um sorry a story from face lislem at the
BBC he said back nine days ago or so
that the obr were there they had a draft
plan ready to give quasiquiteng on his
first day they were ready to to offer
their forecast alongside the mini budget
but he didn't want that because you know
it's all about this idea of of tearing
up the Orthodoxy it's the same reason
that they they got rid of the the
permanent secretary and the whole thing
is as massively as Camilla says spooked
the market and now they're scrabbling
around desperately trying to get some
kind of certainty but it it doesn't look
good does it it looks like they're
desperately sort of chasing their tail
trying to just re-stabilize the markets
as much as they can but for you know
trying to get that conf that level of
confidence back after such a horrendous
shock to the market will be very very
difficult and and I'm not sure that they
have the team around them is capable of
doing that it's not very experienced
team yeah it's a good point and Camilla
your paper goes with Benefits hit as PM
tries to stem the bleeding a number of
papers talk about this welfare payments
to fall in real terms amid warnings of
austerity drive to balance the books
yes so this is picking up on some
research today by the resolution
Foundation Think Tank which points out
that working families are going to be a
thousand pounds a year worse off if
benefits don't rise with inflation and
of course we've got this rampant
inflation at the moment going up and up
and Liz trusses
um written to government departments
telling them they all need to reign in
their spending and make make Cuts
throughout their departments so on the
one hand we've got inflation cutting
into the government's existing budgets
and on the other hand they're being told
to keep well within these um spending
limits so what we're clearly going to
see here is um cuts to to public
services and potentially cuts to
benefits as well at least in real terms
and the article points out that Council
leaders are talking about
um cuts to Leisure centers to adult
social care to Road works so all these
sorts of Public Services that we need
um are going to be scaled back and it
says we're potentially going to see cuts
to Public Funding on the scale not seen
since the austerity years of George
Osborne so that's really quite a
significant
um move by the government all in an
attempt to shore up markets
um but clearly at quite a big cost yeah
Liam the male clear Echoes of Thatcher
here trust I'm not for turning the
question is will she be able to hold out
do you think
well I mean it it really depends on on
the mood of Tory MPS who seem absolutely
terrified for people describing it as as
a you know well swear words I probably
can't repeat on on Sky News so it's how
much time she has she didn't have that
much space on the political scene in the
first place if you remember is only
about 50 MPS that actually backed her
for the job it was obviously the members
that got her over the line so she hasn't
got that broad support in the party
anyway and she couldn't have got off to
a worse start just to pick up on what
Camilla was saying there I I I it does
make me very angry to be honest when
we're going into a cost of living crisis
that that it's basically going to be
people on benefits the lowest earners
the most vulnerable and desperate people
who are essentially going to be paying
for both tax cuts for the rich and for
the disastrous uh chaos that has been
wrought in the country by this
government I I live in an area with
large large levels of deprivation that
has seen brutal brutal cuts to public
services to council Services there is
nowhere left to cut you can't cut the
NHS anymore people are dying in
ambulances can't cook councils money
left the Justice system's a complete
mess this is Liz trust his mistake and
she needs to own it not the people of
the country yeah and uh Camilla I mean
if Tory MPS were worried about this they
certainly will be after this poll
um labor lead by 33 points that's a
staggering that's a staggering lead
for an absolutely huge lead for labor
which means if there was a general
election now they'd put an incredibly
comfortable majority and actually Wipe
Out the Tory party and this is of course
only a few months into Liz truss's
Premiership normally a new prime
minister gets a sort of Bounce in the
polls a bit of confidence a bit of
excitement about their new regime but in
fact it's been the total opposite um
with these polls showing this huge um
labor majority if we were to have a
general election and I think this poll
is just the latest thing that's really
spooked Tori MPS who are already really
feeling
um kind of under the quash from their
constituents angry about the economic
situation about the mini budget and I
spent all day today speaking to
disaffected Tory MPS who are Furious
about what's been happening with the
economy at least previously the
government could sort of blame it on
Ukraine blame it on global forces but
all the Tory MPS are now saying is that
this is a crisis that the government's
own King and clearly we can already see
a direct result of that in the polls
okay Camilla Liam thanks very much
indeed coming up
an extra from the Queen's death
certificate has been released showing
she died of old age we will discuss that
next
[Music]
you're watching the Press preview with
me once again Camilla Turner and Liam
Thorpe let's uh go back to the guardian
Putin set to Annex parts of Ukraine uh
today and uh well Liam I mean it's just
another
tawdry attempt by putting another land
grab there'll be celebrations he's going
to make a speech there's going to be
concerts in Red Square I mean
will the Russian people really fall for
it do you think
you know I think he's been this this
special operation as he call it but
let's call it what it is this this
bloody and and disgraceful Invasion he's
been trying to keep as much of that as
possible away from the Russian people
he's very worried about his he's always
worried about his uh poll ratings which
are really starting to slump now
particularly because he's now obviously
being forced to try and desperately
draft people who simply do not want to
fight we've seen huge numbers of people
trying to escape the country because of
that and now we've got these you know
let's again let's call them what they
are sham referendums what was it
something like 99 one of them came in at
which which would obviously never happen
uh for these for these regions Kirsten
luhans uh donetskin
um what what it is what it is is it a
desperate but a dangerous escalation of
matters because he is getting
increasingly cornered we know Ukraine
have fought back and and won huge
amounts of territory and they they are
still winning back territory in those
same regions of apparently wrongly
apparently just voted for for to be part
of Russia what what it will mean though
is when these the these fake treaties
assigned they will obviously class that
as Russia even though it isn't and
therefore any continued fight back from
Ukraine will be taken to have seen it as
a higher level so it it really increases
the danger but it's it's increasingly
desperate but it is increasingly
dangerous as well but Camilla it does
enable him to you know claim this
Russian territory and say he can he's
going to protect it with all means at
his disposal which you know he suggested
nuclear weapons
yes this is quite a worrying escalation
of the war in Ukraine
um Putin annexing these four quite large
territories in Ukraine claiming that
they're now part of Russia's Sovereign
territory
um and saying that Hill
um be prepared to defend them by all
means necessary so really he's
escalating things quite a bit as the the
fear that by all means necessary
potentially means using nuclear weapons
um it also this development really
scuffers any potential hope there might
have been for for talks for for a
negotiated way after this because of
course for Ukraine it's an absolute red
line to be handing over large parts of
territory to Putin yeah and just very
quickly Liam the queen peaceful death of
the queen from old age says the Express
and the destiny is very moving and very
simple died from old age
yeah I think I think for a lot of people
it will provide quite a lot of comfort
really that you know that it doesn't
sound it certainly doesn't sound like
she was she was suffering particularly
she was a very old lady and she'd done
extremely well for a very very old age
she died peacefully of old age
surrounded by well it was Charles and
and Anne wasn't it her children
um you know I think as things go it's
it's a peaceful it's a peaceful end to
her life
um and I think that will probably bring
a fair amount of comfort for people as
well absolutely uh thank you both